Janice is in Dallas your question for
Ken Coleman Janice thank you for taking
my call okay so I am currently in Dallas
and my husband is still in Florida
my guess is a job opportunity in
aviation back in February and I moved
out here my husband moves me out here it
supposed to come in about here with me
he owns a construction company in
Florida but he changed his mind
so I'm stuck on if I need to if I should
move back and throw away this career
opportunity I'm currently in or if I
should stay here and have come out here
I got before can't answers I got ass
gotta say you understand how weird that
sounds right I know I'm going to move
with my wife but I changed my mind
yo this isn't a career question it's a
marriage question well I'm making fifty
two thousand dollars they're gonna pay
for my pilot's license all the way to my
commercial which takes years his
business fluctuates in income and so I'm
not sure if I should be staying here and
have come out here and started his
career out here and build his business
or if I just need to go back there and
everything may be already decided that
before you moved yeah why did he change
his mind what is he telling you the
reason is there's no opportunity in
Texas for real estate markets dried up
yeah for old Texas economy it just sucks
you've gotta be kidding me that's absurd
I make 50 right now have you been
married Richard and have you been
married yes we've been married for six
months his business right now he's
adding trying to get another dump truck
babbling this is not a business problem
you have deep problems in your marriage
don't you I don't know
well you've been married for six months
your husband is saying he can't go do
construction in Texas because the
economy's bad which is a load of horse
manure if there's something else going
on here kiddo yeah you've been in Dallas
for three months
so of the six months you've been gone
for three you guys have been together
for three months and he doesn't want to
come to Texas for a completely ludicrous
and laughable reason yes well this is a
wake-up call for you
this is a wake up fella yeah I just
don't know what to do there's just the
business has so much debt and I'm just
worried it's gonna go into bankruptcy he
keeps adding more and more debt the
business no and you didn't sign on any
of it did you no but my name is on the
company that doesn't matter doesn't harm
me unless you sign for the deal unless
you sign for stuff did you sign the
debts did you sign any of the debts no
no but he's adding more trucks and this
one this new one that he's won again is
already a hundred and thirty-two K and
he's already got over 100 250 K in
business at home are you I'm going to be
24 soon I'm sorry honey
okay something's going to go by by him
or you in Dallas and it doesn't sound
like he's very committed to you if you
were my daughter I'd be putting my hands
around his little throat right now
because he's being stupid number one
number two he's lying something's going
on because I really want to grow in my
career I got this opportunity I wouldn't
choose I wouldn't choose career over
marriage but I'm afraid I may have
already made the choice for you yeah if
your marriage is going to end you need
to stay there if you can save your
marriage
you want to save your marriage and he
wants to you're gonna go back to Florida
and I want to what he keeps making all
these financial decisions for that's not
just financial decisions honey he
abandoned you he lied to you and he's
lying to you again there's something
going on back home and I'm afraid to say
it out loud because I don't know what
her name is there's no explanation for
this it makes no sense at all let me
just tell you I told Sharon long time
ago if she ever leaves me I'm going with
her that's good let that one sick kid
you know and so if I moved to Dallas
she's coming or vice versa
you know I understand deployment
understand sometimes you're separated by
job on purpose but this is different
this is this has nothing to do with your
career kiddo this has do with your
marriage you need to sit down with
Pastor immediately with a marriage
counselor and get somebody into this
it's not a couple of doobs on the radio
like me and ken because we're not
qualified to help you I'm just a guy
sitting here feeling like a dad ready to
strangle your little husband right now
because somebody's knocking not on his
little head but I can just I smell trash
them all the way here so you need to get
some marriage counseling immediately
with a good pastor and then based on
what's gonna happen with your marriage
you will make your career decisions am I
missing something Ken no absolutely
right he made the commitment to go there
for her so his only reason is so crazy
that nobody would have a brain would
believe it so he's got to come up with
reasons why no opportunity for those
doing construction
Oh God you really need to come up with a
better one than that son you know he's a
coward yeah cuz you come up and excuse
that bad Aaron coward no he's not you
know he's a kid oh my gosh he's a little
boy
I'm sorry honey please get some marriage
counseling and not from my guys like us
we're not qualified but I've just been
down a whole bunch of these roads over
the years with friends family and
everything else and I've watched it
happen and I don't think I don't think
this is going to end well so I think
you're probably going to end up staying
in Dallas it's my guess but um it's not
about the financial decisions that he's
making
that's that those are secondary they're
there they're the symptom in this
situation you know Kent interestingly in
sidebar financial problems
and career problems are both oftentimes
from not really the problem they're
oftentimes a symptom something else
going on in it absolutely the case if
you look at this he keeps adding trucks
he's a young guy
as you said and he wants this business
to grow and he thinks well I'm gonna go
get more and more debt try to build it
faster I've heard you tell us I've heard
you tell leaders I don't know how many
entree leadership conferences I've heard
you use this line you want people to be
on the cover of slow company it's so
there's something that drives a young
entrepreneur to try to do it too quickly
and you try to scale too quickly and you
take debt because you think that's the
way to do it and you wake up and you've
ruined you know that first venture so
there's always something behind it
driving bad decisions so I did the exact
same thing when I was just yeah
not counting the abandoning my wife part
but Wow
[Music]